hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
things in the night okay I got a little
rayji last time to run and so I must
have overlooked something that you guys
pointed out there is apparently a very
very very well-hidden switch right here
gah ah oh that time I could have said I
knew I knew there had to be a switch
somewhere I know it I knew it and now
with your help together we have
conquered now what do we have hell
gordon freeman would be so proud of me i
have a crowbar then i'm going to use it
on the door
well not the door i'm gonna use it on
the wood by the door and i'm gonna move
forward come at me bro
quite literally cuz you get what I'm
saying
I have enough of this ready to move on
it even says used to get to the kitchen
haha not loud enough to bring on the
ball
I need a second to drink this in because
this I have praised this guy's mapmaking
school so far but I have never ever ever
seen anything like this in amnesia
before this is clever use of the
mechanics
click click Piggy's toadstools look
gotcha
hide
move over piggies piggy we're sharing
this yeah we're just gonna this is gonna
have to do piggy oh god it smells so bad
stop pushing is the key to sinning open
the head opens the head servant room I
remember where that was
sup bro yeah
o brother where art thou
where's me do not busting in here
good cuz I got the done ah ah good over
piggy good over let's go guys go number
Oh
here's he doesn't seem like he's busting
in there he's busting some door oh hello
oh he's coming this way oh he's coming
here
oh he's gonna come in here piggy you
better stop squishing I swear
oh all this whole episodes gonna be me
hiding in this closet I am okay with
that right by the piggies okay so you
gotta bust down this door or what cuz
I'm about ready to Jack slap someone I
can hide behind those boxes it's genius
its genius to genius to fail
he'll never find me haha what is the
deal ah that's the all-clear music did
he go away alright haha I lasted him
until he starved to death and/or killed
himself from boredom probably like many
of you did okay add servants room is
down this hall I remember seeing a sign
before that still raining outside oh
wait yes right here quickly she's dark
not fair not cool not fair okay oh
there's no there's no door there head
servants room key I thought I just use
the head servants room key oh no was
that the head servant the disappearing
head servant okay there's very small
paintings ooh
which boy in the piano no okay some funk
click click ah come on there's some
secret switch somewhere there's you find
oh how many voices I can use it one
dingdong damn love Oh nope oh that's
wrong ha ha ha screw me for trying to
think that I was right ah this one is
very specific hello huh disappearing
monsters
okay like that can't like that either
huh huh oh I see you I don't know what
you do but I see you I get it maybe I'll
come in handy later but I see it oh is
this dish Manta I love that flavor of
soda what about a genius can't come up
with great jokes every I can't even
complete says shut up shut up you're
embarrassing me all right okay time to
read this warning is meant for you the
one looking at the snow if anyone is
caught playing with my switches it mean
he's trying to steal my keys so that
person will have to be punished for it
I'm watching you
why'd my lantern go out
kliklak look little evil it there must
be more than one switch in this area
because obviously this opens up nothing
[Music]
okay one down Oh get out of here you so
ugly fast
get your blood out of my face I swear to
God get get really chair stop helping
them geez chair you have been nothing
but unhelpful get your fat ass off the
chair get are you serious are you
serious
you see fine just gather the way I make
sure I compressed it gotta find more
switches oh here's another
ah
okay there was one more switch maybe if
I just ah hit it close it
Oh God is enough not gonna be good
enough it's not good enough [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you what do I do
[ __ ] I'm ready okay I gotta find that
last which ever was
oh yeah there should do something Jer Oh
God oh you want showdown fine [ __ ] you
ready for you her name go crazy looking
at you huh you're not ugly lami back
here Oh
hello baby hey I know I know
I know I failed but I'd never fail you I
wouldn't fail you either baby
okay well that's sucked that suck don't
give all but I must carry on as the note
said right here all right there was a I
tried to get this one but it wasn't
working there must be a another one
around here
god I hate looks for these switches
they're like impossible to see make sure
I check behind everything round
now to oil again and then I'm not gonna
be able to see it's not under a plan or
something you know I'm gonna run out of
please last oil ah like that do a story
ah what right everyone about-face
ah so screwed
ah so sorry because here goes my Oi 3 2
oh sorry I got more time than I thought
ha ha maybe under school they can't even
pick up the school nevermind I probably
hit 3 - what uh premature
okay fine now I'm out of oil again oh
god I mean some custom stories like they
just drown me in oil this one's very
spirit which is good it's good I mean
it's good to have you know a resource
system where you you don't have infinite
everything I mean I'm not saying that I
should have infinite oil but maybe I
should have been a little smarter about
it no no no I'm gonna go ahead and
assume that it's not my fault not my
fault all right
I do not see this other switch that's
where I'm looking I'm looking
oh it's gonna be this thing again I mean
there's got to be another one beside it
right there's none in here it's none
that I could see maybe there's one like
the back of the drawer
oh god oh no I don't know in the
fireplace got that one got the one at
the desk got that one with a badass is
still laying there like a lazy son of a
[Music]
I don't know what the deal is maybe in
the other room
it could be because the head servant had
more than one row
there's this weird door here
but I can't see anything
I do have tinderboxes plenty of those
gather a chair you can look behind stuff
if you look in stuff look around stuff
get off your barrels get out
ah get now write whatever you can stay
there looking for switch but no find no
find looking for slits again no fine no
okay it's got it's got to be in that
room he's got to me so let me stop this
was a troll switch that was a troll
switch ha ha
just like how I like them just how I
like him like I like him wouldn't be it
would be would work but it wouldn't be
the best grammatical formation of a
second every master has been really
strange he's always gone in the lab at
five servants is gone missing I tried to
talk with him about this subject but all
he said was delenn was that he let them
go but neither do I or even his son
think that's what's really happening
is he killing them no I can't be right
maybe they were helping him in the lab
and just don't want anyone to know about
it they are servants after all I was
attacked last night in the hallway it's
too dark to see anything but something
definitely scratched me I ran like hell
to my rooming to get some light so I
could see better but by that time they
were gone they we're gone I'm getting
sick from that scratch so Master said
he's going to take me if he was allowed
to check my condition he said that maybe
he can tell me there okay so anyway I
don't all the time I got for this
episode thank you all so much for
watching hope you enjoyed it and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye